i think everything that my grandmother
wanted to
achieve when she took this huge
responsibility on
she she's managed yeah you heard him
correctly
that's prince harry giving some major
love to his granny the queen
following he and wife meghan markle's
royal exit
and the release of the controversial new
biography
finding freedom i'm sure this will make
for uncomfortable reading for some
people it does go into the lives of
family relations between royal family
members but of course these are people
who are
living out there already in the public
eye
this is a conversation about using
digital the online world for good
the sussex is hopped on a zoom call with
young leaders on monday
as part of the queen's commonwealth
trust marking
their first joint appearance from their
new home in santa barbara
it's good to be home as for why megan
and harry are
still carrying out royal duties the
decision that
i have made for my wife and i to step
back
is not one i made lightly well even
after stepping back as senior members of
the family on march 31st
the sussexes have held on to a few roles
including that of president and vice
president of the queen's commonwealth
trust
thank you for giving me the courage to
take this next step
and they used monday's meeting about
spreading positivity in the digital
space
to give a little praise to queen
elizabeth herself
everything that my grandmother wanted to
achieve when she took this huge
responsibility on
she she's managed no one could have
predicted how the world was going to
change in
in such a short space of time especially
with the digital space but
hearing you guys knowing the broad
spectrum
that the the qct sort of engulfs
you guys are the definition of the 21st
century commonwealth and what it means
to be part of it you know you are there
standing for
equality for mutual respect and for
fairness
plus megan gave her own nod to the 94
year old monarch
from my standpoint being newer to the
the world of the commonwealth right i
lived in canada for several years but it
wasn't until joining the family and
um that i was able to meet so many young
people throughout the commonwealth
if they came with a question they always
offered a solution
and that's what i think is so inspiring
and you know why i'm incredibly proud to
to be able to work with the queen's
commonwealth trust but why you know it's
it's the continuation of the legacy of
your grandmother
the couple continued to spread the love
complimenting the young leaders on their
work
i think this platform that you guys have
created is
is so it's just optimistic right it's so
positive and that's exactly what you
guys need you can either train people to
be cruel or you can train people to be
kind
and it's really that simple and harry
had
this message about mental health if we
are all able to show our vulnerability
that doesn't mean that you're weak
if anything i believe that's probably
showing most of your strength
and if you're so in touch with your
emotions and you know where you are on
each day
well that's a superpower but no sussex
appearance is
complete without a nod to archie and
thankfully the proud mama delivered i
say you i want to include us i really
feel i already feel as i'm
way too old for a conversation no no but
it's true
but it's true it's it's this is the
world that you guys are going to inherit
i'm saying you guys because i'm
predicting that most of you and your and
are in your late twenties
[Music]